ونتابع واياكم من انطلاق الجائحه من الصين
واليها تعود عوده تهدد من جديد العالم
بتفشن وبائيا جديد ومتحورات مستجده قد
تربك العالم وتعيد الى اذهانه كابوس
الاغلاقات تشهد الصين زياده كبيره في
اعداد الاصابات بعدما رفعت الشهر الماضي
فجاه ومن دون استعدادات تذكر قيودا صارمه
للحد من تفشيكو امر احدث ضغطا كبيرا على
المستشفيات ومحارق الجثث زياده وصلت الى
نسب مرتفعه جدا اذا افادت وزاره الصحه
الكوريه الجنوبيه بان واحدا من كل خمسه
وافدين من الصين الى كوريا الجنوبيه مصاب
بفيروس كورونا المستجد ما دفع الحكومه
الكوريه لفرد اجراء اختبار بي سي ار على
الوافدين من الصين خلال اليوم الاول من
وصولهم بعد ما تاكد امس اصابه واحد 61
واحدا عبر مطار الدولي بالفايروس
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
الفن و 52 وفد بمن فيهم طاقم خطوط الطيران
خضع منهم 300 وتسعه اجانب لبي سي ار فورا
وصولهم وتبين ان واحدا 61 شخصا ايمن نسبته
19.7 مصاب بفيروس كورونا
ويلزم الوافدون من الصين بمن فيهم
المواطنون الكوريون والاجانب المقيمون
لمده اكثر من 90 يوما باستثناء المقيمين
الاجانب لمده اقل من ذلك بالخضوع لاختبار
بي سي ار في غضون يوم واحد من دخولهم
لكنها سول ليست الوحيده التي بدات بفرض
قيود على القادمين من الصين جوا فالولايات
المتحده واعتبارا من الخامس من يناير
سيتعين على جميع المسافرين جو ممن تبلغ
اعمارهم عامين فاكثر تقديم نتيجه سلبيه
لفحص اجريه قبل يومين على الاقل من مغادره
الصين او هونج كونج او ماكاو كذلك حدث
بريطانيا وفرنسا احد والولايات المتحده بل
حظه باريس جميع دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاخرى البالغ عددها 26 دوله على فحص
المسافرين الصينيين لرصد الاصابات بيكو ضد
استراليا وكندا والهند للركب اليابان
وتايوان وماليزيا بدورها اتخذت الخطوات
نفسها واعلن طوكيو ان الحكومه ستحد من
الطلبات المقدمه من شركات الطيران لزياده
الرحلات الى الصين ومن العالم العربي
اتخذت كل من المغرب وقطر اجراءات الممثله
امام القادمين من الصين
تؤدي الحكومه واجبها في حمايه الفرنسيين
من خلال طلب الاختبارات المسافرون من
الصين الى فرنسا يتعهدون بقبول اجراء
الاختبار عند وصولهم ما يساعدنا في الحصول
على بيانات حول تطور الفيروس والتاكد من
وجوده نفعل ذلك مع احترام كامل لقواعد
منظمه الصحه
غير المقبوله ضد الوافدين من اراضيها بل
وهددت باتخاذ اجراءات مضاده مبنيه على
مبدا المعامله بالمثل الخارجيه والصينيه
وقالت ان بعض البلدان فرضت قيودا على دخول
المسافرين تستهدف الصينيين فقط مشيره الى
ان ذلك يفتقر على اساس او الى اساس علمي
وتعد بعض الممارسات غير مقبوله كما اعتبره
[موسيقى]
كويتي مستعدون للتواصل مع العالم للتغلب
على رائحه كورونا لكننا نعتقد ان قيود
الدخول التي فرضتها بعض الدول على الصين
تفتقر الى الاساس العلمي وبعض الممارسات
في غير المقبوله الصين تعارض بشده محاولات
التلاعب باجراءات الوقايه من الوباء
ومكافحته لاغراض سياسيه وسنتخذ الاجراءات
المناسبه وفقا لمبدا المعامله بالمثل